all right let's do this one last time
fan ofstreet meat huh well how do you feel about cold pork
seems like no matter how many messes
i clean up every multiverse has another set of numbskulls
you've got criminals robots shape-shifters evil
scientists arms dealers politicians and it goes on
and on and on you know you're all pretty lucky
i'm so good at superheroing is that a word
looking to find your trip to stardom your time in
the limelight go on then today's your lucky day
mojo world incorporated is accepting new
applicants for our saturday morning time slots
report for an audience of devoted fans be admired
near and far become famous overnight how famous
huh are we talking like a niche kid's cartoon
that adults also sort of love famous or but
wait there's more answer all right you can't hear
me work under the illustrious mojo himself whose
overwhelming power and influence and viewership
will help you achieve your wildest dreams at
mojo world when mojo wins we all win that doesn't
sound that sinister right right excuse me what now
well that commercial was weirder than tofu
bacon but i could be famous people would
actually laugh when i pause for laughter huh
i wonder where i can find this mojo guy anyway
Qelcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new spider-man into the spider-verse 2
video they just released this new promo featuring
a whole bunch of easter eggs some tom holland some
venom so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're also doing a giveaway for
the spider-man miles morales playstation 5 game
or the playstation 4 version depending on which
version you have all you have to do to enter that
is be a subscriber and let me know what kind of
easter eggs and versions of spider-man you want
to see in spider-verse 2. but if you didn't see
it marvel just released this new spider-man into
the spider-verse clip featuring john mullaney's
spider-ham tom holland full-blown venom and a
bunch of other marvel characters from different
universes like we have mojo there's even ultron
in the background so this is them just having fun
with that character doing a tie-in promo featuring
way more multiverse stuff than they did in the
first film if you didn't buy the blu-ray for the
first spider-man into the spider-verse movie they
did something like this for that only it was like
a full-blown bonus cartoon episode for spider-ham
just featuring a bunch of extra content i'll
explain that a little bit at the end of the video
but if you don't remember tom holland actually did
an interview after the first spider-verse movie
came out explaining that he was about to be in
the movie with a special cameo scene but at the
last second the sony people said no dice to the
producers at one point i was supposed to be in it
yeah there was going to be another peter parker
like it was like a scene in a train station or
something and and like it was it was going to
be like a like an easter egg i was going to walk
through the background and say like hey kid or
something and never happened heartbroken um but
i'm just excited for us to introduce miles into
our own universe one day i think that's going
to be really cool should be wild yeah it should
be a wild wild time tom can you tell us about
the spider verse honestly mate i'm sick of this
spider verse stuff right i'm the only spider-man
it's me only one there ever is and ever will greg
sorry lord and miller explained that it was
all part of their idea to go full spider verse
and have cameo scenes from all the previous
live-action spider-man movie actors including
toby mcguire and andrew garfield coming back as
their versions of spider-man it's too bad that
didn't work out the first time but this is them
just teasing that they'll eventually get to that
tom hall and toby maguire andrew garfield stuff
eventually in the animated spider-man into the
spider-verse movies yes i know there are rumors
about live-action spider-verse stuff happening
during tom hall and spider-man 3 movie they're
still in the middle of filming that right now
tom holland has been posting a lot of stuff from
behind the scenes on his social media accounts but
right now most of the scenes that they're filming
as of me posting this video are inside a studio so
we can't actually see what they're filming they
were filming outside a couple weeks ago doing
some big web-slinging stunts with spider-man and
zendaya's mj just confirming they'll be continuing
that joke of her flipping the hell out when he
takes her web slinging this time not so much for
fun though because the whole premise of spider-man
3 is that he's wanted by everyone the world thinks
he killed mysterio because of that fake video
footage he released to j jonah jameson in the
daily bugle but if you wondered why they had that
funny mj scene at the end of spider-man far from
home this is why like she says we're never doing
that again in movie logic holds true the minute a
character says they're never doing something again
it means that they're doubling down and doing it
way more in the sequel cranked up to eleven it's
not really a new concept him swinging around
with mj they did it all the time during the toby
mugar spider-man era and during andrew garfield
the funny thing about the web slinging scenes
during the first spider-man movie though is if
you look at it the way they filmed it her hair
actually blows the wrong direction just because
of the actual technology that they used to film
these scenes and if you really look at it you
can kind of tell that she's using a mannequin
to swing around like this so obviously over the
last 15 years the technology that they use
to film these types of scenes has evolved
but there have been a bunch of fan trailers and
clips posting online for spider-man 3 there was
a sony producer who claimed we get an official
teaser trailer of some kind or a preview of some
sort before the end of the year and guess what it
is the end of the year as of me posting this video
the big cc xp worlds convention is this weekend
and all the major studios are doing panels warner
brothers is even doing a full-blown six-hour panel
on sunday for all their movies and new tv shows
they have coming to hbo max marvel i believe
is doing some kind of panel i haven't heard
anything official about what sony is planning
but pretty safe bet that they'll have some sort
of tom holland spider-man 3 preview maybe a new
morbius trailer maybe another first look or a
teaser for venom 2 whatever they wind up releasing
or any new information about the movies of course
i'll totally make videos for it so no worries
all that starts this friday i believe as long
as you have alerts enabled for my channel you'll
see any of the videos that i post for that but i
don't think the really big stuff is happening
till saturday and sunday the other really big
surprise from this promo is the full-blown venom i
think we all expected them to do some venom easter
eggs during the animated spider-verse movies
eventually we just didn't know when or which
version of venom it would be because we have the
ultimate spider-man version which is miles morales
from the comics and some of the other versions
that they've done in the spider-verse movie are
straight out of the comics but for instance jay
johnson's 40-something midlife crisis spider-man
is meant to be an amalgam of every live-action
version of spider-man so far that's why during
the let's do this one last time version of his
origin story they have the toby mcguire spider-man
train scene the upside down kiss in the rain the
andrew garfield the tom holland stuff all baked
in he's not meant to be any one specific comic
book version of the character but if venom winds
up being a featured character in the new movie or
one of the future sequels no idea who they get to
voice him they did such a good job with that first
movie that i totally trust their judgment when
it comes to picking which versions of spider-man
to do and casting the voice actors whatever they
wind up doing it's going to be awesome right
now though the animated spider-verse 2 movie
is currently supposed to be released october 7
2022 it's still a ways off that's just because
the animation is so complex it takes forever to
finish for example it took an army of animators
about four years to make that first spider-burst
movie so that's why it's taking them about four
years to get the sequel out the other day you may
have also caught the official spider-man into the
spider-verse twitter account releasing new teasers
of the different versions of spider-man that
they've confirmed will show up during spider-verse
2. most of them we already know about from the
first teaser trailer they released last year with
the different spider-man logos i've already done
a separate video explaining all those different
versions so i'll add a link at the end of this
and in the description if you want to learn about
all those different versions the only one that
lord and miller have actually confirmed openly
is japanese spider-man supeida man marvel even
just released a full-blown documentary episode
about that character as part of their new marvel
616 disney plus series during that they actually
reveal that stanley himself saved the show from
being canned early on if you're not familiar
with the backstory on the japanese spider-man
it's not an alternate version of peter parker
the person's name is takuya yamashiro he gets
his powers from an alien i know it sounds kind of
crazy he has accessories like the special gp7 car
and his giant robot is named leopardon and that's
really what people think of when they think of
japanese spider-man that giant mech i can't wait
to see how they include that in spider-verse 2.
but as for that other big bonus cartoon that
they released with the first movie if you didn't
get the blu-ray it features a much larger origin
story for spider-ham way longer than this promo it
plays like a super-sized version of the quicker
spider-ham monologue scene when he's explaining
his backstory a regular old spider that was bitten
by a radioactive pig that's why it's not weird for
him to eat hot dogs you may remember all the memes
when the movie came out because there was actually
promos of him eating hot dogs some people who
didn't know his backstory started to flip but
if we get any more details about spider-verse
2 or they release any kind of trailer or teaser
for spider-man 3 venom 2 or morbius this month at
ccxp or somewhere else of course i'll do videos
everyone click here for my new mandalorian season
2 episode 5 ahsoka tano video and click here for
that other spider-man into the spider-verse
2 trailer with all the different versions
of the character thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!